So unfortunately we're not
quite ready to be all smiley.
Sebastian tells me it's going to be
a few years before I can get my own
self-driving car, but
the bigger problem is we haven't yet
talked about how to
actually use a procedure.
All we've done is make them.
Until we can actually use them,
we don't have a good reason
to be really happy yet.
But we're going to learn
how to use them next, and
then we'll be back to being smiley.
So now we're going to learn
how to use a procedure.
The way to use a procedure,
we need the name of the procedure,
followed by a left paren,
followed by a list of inputs.
And there could be any number of inputs,
but
it has to match the number of
inputs the procedure expects.
These inputs are sometimes called,
operands.
They're sometimes called, arguments.
But, we're not going to
argue about that.
We're just going to call them inputs.
So you've actually already done
something quite similar to this.
Back in unit one,
you learned about using find on strings.
And with find,
you would pass in one or two inputs.
The first input was a string.
That was the string that
you're looking for.
That's the first input.
And the second input could be a number,
the position where you start looking for
that string.
And so we used find in many
ways in unit one as well as you
used it yourself in the homework for
unit one.
Find is a little different from
the procedures that you define yourself.
First of all, it's built in.
The other thing that was different
is that instead of just having find,
we had another input that
was really over here.
Right.
We had the string that we're doing
the find in,
let's say it was in the variable page.
That's really another input to find.
We'll talk in a later class about
why that's done differently, but
it's very similar to calling a procedure
where one of the inputs is over here,
the other two are here.
It's a little different from that and
we won't get into that in this course.
But in a later course, you'll learn
more about what this really means.
For all the procedures
that you define yourself,
we won't have any object
to invoke them on.
We'll just have to procedure to call and
the arguments or operands, or
inputs, as you like to call them,
to pass in.
So let's see how that works
with a simple procedure.
I'm going to find the procedure
Rest_of_string and
we'll give it the parameter s.
So that means it takes one input and
we're going to use the name,
s, to refer to the value of that input.
And we'll make it return the string
from the first character to the end.
So we'll use the string
indexing operator, return s 1:.
This will evaluate to the string,
with the first letter removed, so
all strings from position one
until the end of the string.
And that's what we return, so
that's the output of rest_of_string,
is that new string that starts from
the second letter in the input string.
Here's an example of how
to use this procedure.
So we could call it directly.
So we could say, print rest_of_string.
So that's our procedure.
Now we're going to have our paren,
and we're going to pass in an input.
There's one parameter to rest_of_string,
so we need one input to pass in, and
it should be a string.
So I'll pass in the string, audacity.
What happens when we call
a procedure like this?
Execution will jump into
the body of the procedure.
So we can think of what the interpreter
is doing is, now instead of
running the code here, the interpreter
will move when we call a procedure.
It will jump to run the code
inside the procedure.
It will assign to the parameters,
the values passed in as the inputs.
So we can think of this as
there being an assignment
that says now the value of s is the
value of this input that was passed in.
And now we're going to evaluate
the body of the procedure.
In this case, there's only one
statement, is this return statement.
We're going to find this value,
so s[1:],
the result of that is going to
be the string, udacity.
And then we got to the return.
What return means is
we're going to jump back.
We're jumping back to where
we called the procedure, but
now we actually have a result.
So when we jump back the value that this
evaluates to is whatever
value we returned.
In this case, it's the string udacity.
So, we don't have our self-driving car,
but now you can define and
use procedures.
This is a really powerful concept.
Anything that we're going to do
in the rest of the course, and
anything almost anyone does
in programming computers
is all about defining procedures and
using procedures.
So now we should have a big smile.
We can think of our procedures in
terms of mapping inputs to outputs.
We can think of our humans as
also mapping inputs to outputs.
We have inputs coming in through
the eyes, through the mouth,
maybe we even have a nose.
And, I won't try to draw any of
the outputs of our human procedure.
But, since procedures are such
an important concept,
we're going to have several quizzes now,
to check that you understand them well.